do you think you have to be empathic or
open to be a good writer I mean isn't
that the job of being right here is to
tell you know the story of humans I mean
you can you can certainly write a
blockbuster movie I mean I know that
there there are a lot of big studio
platforms out there that just you know
tell and I'm not going to name any
particular films but there are some that
just don't have character they're all
action and maybe storylines but yeah I
think in order to to tell stories that
people gravitate to you you have to be
willing to tell you know a little bit of
yourself on each one one thing that
people always ask you when you are
writing is why are you the person to
tell this story
why why why should you be the voice of
this and it's easier to I don't wanna
say prove but it's easier to persuade
people that you are the right person to
tell a particular story if you yourself
can relate to it
I think that's what we're all looking
for you know any time that we go to a
movie we're looking to experience a kind
of catharsis you know we're looking to
experience some kind of human emotion
I find that my best pieces my best work
are the ones that I've really put myself
into and they have a bit of me in like
like the Baltimore school of charm
there's a reason that story is so
impactful there's a reason that it
resonates with people is because it's
it's inspired by my family it's it's
it's something that you know I've lived
through it's something that other women
have lived through it's it's a bit of me
on that page absolutely you need to be
empathetic sure and at the same time
being empathetic and open also has its
drawbacks and that may be things wound
do you more or or it's it's more intense
for you so how are you able to be open
and sensitive to things that are coming
at you for story ideas but then also be
able to receive notes
and sometimes they're not always going
to be positive or go into a room and
maybe you read that room and it's not
friendly because I think that that's
learning the writing process you can
learn you know is it's like let's
imagine we're building a building you've
got to have some kind of a floor plan to
do it right
you've got to know the rules before you
can break them so if you can learn
structural engineering and how to put it
together then you can shape it into
whatever shape you want it to be you
know you can you can make a skyscraper
with you know turrets on it if you want
it to but it that's how you that's how
you find your voice that's how you start
making stories your own learn the rules
before you break them so you know you
can't tell such an emotionally overdrawn
story you know for where you've got your
lead and crying or being assaulted or
abused for you know two and a half hours
nobody's gonna want to see that I think
that you as a writer need to understand
that you have a duty to your audience to
make sure you tell a story that moves
forward and they tell a story that
progresses don't skimp on character
certainly save those those moments you
know of great emotion but learn how to
construct your story first you're
serving a lot of masters when you're
when you're writing and if you don't
have good structure I mean unfortunately
that's your story will fall apart how
does someone become good as a writer you
said at first you weren't sure you could
do it but you wanted to definitely learn
have that as a safeguard you didn't want
to just try it and say you were a writer
without doing it you know I still have
problems saying I'm a writer I don't
know when you ever become good I mean if
you're if you're Maya Angelou or
somebody like that then you're
definitely a good writer but I think I
don't know I think I think asking
yourself the question always wanting to
be better always knowing that you can
dig deeper and always finding that you
can do something better that will help
you lead to improving your process and I
I I want to stay away from using labels
like good or great because that kind of
puts you know that puts a lot of
pressure on yourself
especially for somebody that's just
starting out you have to be okay with
failing
you only need one story to spark the
next thing in your career I failed for
three years with with Baltimore and then
when I finally got it right it struck
the right chord what do you think the
difference was just working on it just
honing it I think I think it was my
dogged perseverance of not giving up on
it I I wanted people to see what I saw
and I had to find a way to communicate
that out and I think just writing Draft
after Draft after Draft after draft and
I've probably gone through 30 iterations
of that script you know with time with
time I've certainly gotten better I've
improved my own process so I can shorten
that writing cycle but the first one I
had no idea what I was doing what were
some of the notes that you got and how
much of the feedback did you incorporate
to change I mean I incorporated feedback
from a variety of sources I incorporated
it from some of the competitions that I
was in some of the instructors at UCLA
character was one of the things that
people would really hone in on I mean
obviously there are things like well
this is a bit of a plot hole you may
want to look at this but those are the
obvious things but people would always
talk about making the character more in
depth like what what little things can
you do to to make a character stick out
in someone's mind there's a a second
female lead in Baltimore it's a young
girl named Shasta she's 17 and so I
wanted there's there's a relationship
between Millie the lead and Shasta so
Millie is trying to outrun the law and
she gets stuck in a small town where you
know she can't get out of it and she
ends up helping Shasta the young girl
there but Shasta has has a stutter so
that was one thing that I was able to to
develop with Shasta initially she didn't
have a stutter but she I gave her that
impediment to help show
her relationship with the world around
her so I think that there are certain
traits there are certain mannerisms
there are certain things that you can do
to you know just build up your character
and obviously give them a backstory but
that will inform the decisions on how
they interact with the world did you
miss the two characters when you were
finished writing was it hard for you to
give them up um I tell you what's gonna
be hard for me is when it gets made you
know as a writer you typically don't
have any control over something when it
leaves your hands so I hope that the
company that ends up buying Baltimore
school of charm I hope that they do
those characters justice because it's
not a lot it's not a movie of the week
you know it's it's certainly not a
melodrama it's it's a very strong
powerful piece and it's my hope that a
female director well won't end up
helming it I think that that's important
to actually authentically tell the story
you know they're they're like your
characters are like your children when
you send them out and the worst that you
hope that they they're received well and
that they do well what were so the feet
the feedback initially was that the the
character at least the main one wasn't
as fleshed out and so you really worked
on making her just more
three-dimensional more three-dimensional
yeah and so when you finally sorry you
won it was the UCLA screenwriting
competition okay
they're extension they're extension okay
and so they these different agencies
just found your emails obviously no what
happened is when when there are
different categories within the the
competition so it's best feature it's
best spec pilot and then best pilot so
and then you're ranked one two and three
so there's a total of nine Awards that
give out that they've given out and then
there's you know obviously first place
second place third place so when they
send the announcement out and they've
got a list of you know thousands of
executives and agents that you know
they've spent years cultivating
relationships with when the announcement
goes out they put out an ad in variety
announcing it and then they also do a
mass
to all of these executives so that's how
they got tipped off and you know you you
put first-place feature on a competition
like that and it's going to spark some
interest and fortunately it did and
fortunately it got me you know the reps
that I have today so been part of having
a rep is they're submitting you to work
on shows like how does this work um so
typically what happens in a move there's
a there's an issue right now with the
WGA and the ATA so I'm not gonna I'm not
going to go into that in this particular
interview because I'm there are many
people that are much more positioned or
much better position to speak on that
than I am but typically what happens is
you know if you've got a aspect pilot or
a spec feature they will take that
material and they will send it out to
different exalt development execs and
studios and you know see if it's a match
and they could you know you can write on
assignment so let's just say if you meet
with the development exact and they like
your writing and like well I've got this
project would you be interested in
taking a crack at it so so that's the
job of an agent is to find their clients
work and so how much advance notice do
you get when you have a meeting I have
one this week that has been on my
calendar for six weeks and that's good
so you have your outfit everything's
ready yeah I had one a couple weeks ago
I had a general a couple weeks ago and
she said she actually had an intern and
she asked if it was okay if the interns
sat in on the meeting that's totally
fine I mean I'm it wasn't gonna throw me
off my game but we talked about it later
she was like she was like I think you
set the bar a little too high for
generalists because she said we've had
some interesting people coming here she
said yeah I'm one of the one of the
worst pieces of advice that I've ever
heard writers being given is to dress
like your genre I was like what does
that mean she was like I don't know she
but I was like I don't I was like what
what is what are you supposed to do I
guess if you read action-adventure
you're supposed to dress I don't know
but don't do that that's bad advice
so just wear something like you know
business casual or I mean don't dress
like a schlub you know make sure that
you look professional and neat
clothes that you're comfortable in I'm
sure you're not you're not trying to
over impress you know you're just just
yourself just look neat and professional
just be yourself then how long did it
take for you to develop sort of like the
pitch that is you because they want to
ask you this and sometimes people are
comfortable and then sometimes so tell
me about yourself how long did that take
it changes every time I go into a room
you have to learn how to reach your
audience because you may be dealing with
somebody who is more closed off and
maybe they don't want to know so much
personal information about yourself I
think instead of developing your pitch
you need to know how to really need to
know your story because you need you
can't tell your pitch the same way every
single time because then it sounds
canned it sounds like you're reading it
off of an index card and nobody wants to
be you know read a PowerPoint slide you
need to be in a position to
authentically tell your story any even
you know notice